Gabby and her fiancé embarked
on a cross-country trip
in Gabby's 2012 white Ford van.
It was like every parent's nightmare.
Just like, in a flash of a second.
She's gone. She's missing.
Let's just take a minute,
step back and breathe.
The thoughts that were going
through my head were something,
something really bad
has happened to her.
That time when we were
looking for Gabby was...
-Horrific.
-It's a blur.
It's really like a...
It's horrific.
The media and the
internet just went crazy.
I think the hashtag #FINDGABBY
hit like over a billion people.
Her bright, beautiful light
touched a lot of people.
I am gonna walk down here a
little bit because I see something.
Right here...
okay, is where they think that
it's a shadow of someone digging.
There was definitely
more to this relationship
than was being
shown on social media.
So, a body has been found
in the area that they were
searching for Gabby Petito.
It's still unbelievable.
I don't understand it.
These are all I have left now.
I really don't know what justice
for Gabby looks like at this point.
Everybody deserves
to feel safe at home.
Everybody deserves to
be found that is missing.
Everyone.